my own personal experience with abortion
and I don't think we talk about this
enough abortion can be another word for
Mercy our country has
I'm very excited about this daily
cancellation I finally get a chance to
cancel Ann Hathaway I've held a grudge
against this woman ever since my wife
early in our marriage forced me to go to
the theater with her with her mom and
her sister to watch Les Miserables it
was the worst experience of my life
actor in the film was deeply and
painfully annoying none of them would
stop singing at all they sang the entire
time from start to finish yet even
amidstall of that Anne Hathaway managed
to be
irritating and insufferable on a level
that even Russell Crowe's blubbering
off-key performance couldn't reach
oh years later I went with much higher
hopes to go see Interstellar and there
was Anne Hathaway again helping to ruin
the film with her cringy saccharin
speeches about the Transcendent Power of
Love I wanted to see a movie about deep
space exploration I was hoping there'd
be aliens instead I got no aliens only a
little bit of space exploration in
exchange for a lot of scenes of Anne
Hathaway and Jessica Chastain's sulking
and whining and giving corny sermons
The only thing that would made it worse
is if they started singing
thankfully they didn't all that to say
this cancellation is a long time coming
Hathaway's appearance this week on The
View has I think finally provided me the
opportunity that I've been waiting for
let's watch the devilish product didn't
turn 16 this summer yes the time flies
boy so you wrote this on Instagram code
I am struck by the fact that the young
female characters in this movie built
their lives and careers in a country
then honored their right to have Choice
over their own reproductive Health see
you in the fight so why did you write
that why was it important to you to you
to write something like that because
we're in the fight yeah we're in the
fight every day we're in the fight every
minute and you mentioned the devil's
product turning sweet 16 yeah some 16
year old's life has been irrevocably
changed yeah because of the current
overturning of Roe v Wade I think about
it all the time I think we all think
about it all the time and um
and what its implications are and what
it means to live in a country that
puts us in this position again again
freaking again I guess here we go again
this is not a moral conversation about
abortion right this is a practical
conversation about women's rights and by
the way human rights because women's
rights are human rights and the freedom
that we all need to be able to to choose
and build our lives and have access to
excellent health care so let's try to
sift through this she says that uh it
Grieves her to consider that the young
female characters in Devil Wears Prada
would not be able to have abortions if
the film was set in the current day it
is to begin with extremely strange to
worry about the availability of abortion
for fictional characters also again not
having seen it my impression is that the
movie has a rather dim view of selfish
career-obsessed people
um that's like the Devil Wears Prada
that's so part of the moral of the story
from what I understand is that there's
more to life than professional ambition
yet Hathaway's takeaway is that women
need to be able to kill their children
so they can focus more on career
advancement
there seems to be a little bit of a
disconnect here she also speaks about
reproductive Destiny which of course is
exactly the sort of asinine hackneyed
phrase you would expect Anne Hathaway to
use when discussing abortion
um it's it's it's not the sort of
warning that I would ever choose
but since she brought it up
let us ask this question once a woman
has conceived a child
what is her reproductive Destiny the
word destiny implies a force outside of
the individual a message a mission from
Beyond ourselves so what is this Force
call it nature call it the universe call
it as I do God what is this Force trying
to say to the woman what is her Destiny
now that she has conceived the child in
her womb is it her Destiny to partake in
the joy and beauty and fulfillment of
motherhood good idea oh Lord cause it's
a good idea or is it her Destiny to Peg
some abortionist to kill her baby and
throw his body into a medical waste
dumpster I would say the former indeed
how could it be anyone's reproductive
Destiny to reject their reproductive
capacity and violently destroy the human
life that they have reproduced to call
such a choice reproductive Destiny seems
uh bizarre to say the least Hathaway
also claims that she's not interested in
having a moral conversation about
abortion but rather a practical
conversation about women's rights
well except that
a conversation about rights is
automatically a conversation about
morality you cannot extract the concept
of morality from the concept of Human
Rights
a practical conversation a real
practical conversation is one that is
not concerned with theories or ideas at
all but human rights are a theory they
are an idea they're a moral idea that
isn't to say they don't exist but rather
that they exist in the moral realm they
don't exist physically practically like
a chair or a rock or the ocean exists so
to say that you don't want to talk about
morality you just want to talk about
human rights that is to speak gibberish
human rights are a moral concept the
minute you bring them up you have
entered into the moral realm but that's
not where Anne Hathaway wants to be
because she knows that she can't
actually defend abortion on moral
grounds none of these people can
and that's the issue but she had more to
say and it only gets dumber from here so
let's continue without going to too many
details my own personal experience with
abortion and I don't think we talk about
this enough abortion can be another word
for mercy
we know that no two pregnancies are
alike and it follows that no two lives
are like that follows that no two
conceptions are alike so how can we have
a law how can we have a point of view on
this that says we must treat everything
the same and where I come at it from is
when you allow for choice you allow for
flexibility which is what we need in
order to be human
abortion is another word for Mercy she
says but Mercy For Whom genocide Mercy
Mercy for the child who's being killed
that's not Mercy that child has an
entire life ahead of him or he should
you're taking that away You're deciding
for him that his life is not worth
living you're erasing all of his
potential all that could have been
there's no mercy in that it's the
opposite of Mercy because it's the
opposite of empathy and you can't have
mercy without empathy or do you mean
that it's merciful to the woman are you
saying that killing a child is an act of
Mercy to the child's mother well no
mercy to the mother is to help her to
give her the resources she needs Mercy
is what pregnancy centers provide Mercy
is their Ministries what they do
abortion clinics on the other hand are
vultures they prey on fear and misery
they cash in on it they feed off of it
they profit off of it they sell guilt
they sell regret they sell loneliness
while taking away the love and joy of
motherhood that's not Mercy it's
mercenary so whichever way Hathaway
meant it she's wrong though I'm not sure
she knows how she meant it because she's
just babbling which is what most
defenses of abortion boil down to
incoherent Babel and that is why Anne
Hathaway is today finally after all
these years cancer
what's the biggest summer secret to a
great looking glowing summer complexion
it's having great skin care products
from our friends at genu sale you know
dehydrated skin covered in dark spots
and even puffier bags under the eyes are
a problem for all of us gender cells
beautifully curated summer Essentials
package is a limited edition package
that includes their one-of-a-kind Ultra
retinol super moisturizer their Ultra
retinol is a powerful plant extract
alternative to retinol without the harsh
side effects and it's perfectly safe for
use in the Summer sun plus you'll get
geniusell's classic skin care therapy
for under eye bags and puffiness and
concentrated vitamin C serum to nourish
your skin for a visibly clear complexion
with a glow that will get compliments
everywhere you go our assistant director
Austin has freakishly large under eye
bags and they seem to be growing every
day it looks like his skin is slowly
shriveling up and it's all just becoming
one giant under eye bag it's grotesque
to look at needless to say it's
extremely upsetting for me really puts
me in a bad head space before I start my
show so I've forced Austin to start
using genucel and just like magic his
eyes no longer look like they uh packed
bags for a month-long vacation overseas
so go to genyourself.com Walsh YT right
now to get your genusel summer
Essentials package just for the summer
every subscription order includes a
customized summer spa gift box
absolutely free it's genusal.com Walsh
YT genucel.com Walsh White
foreign
for our daily cancellation we turn to
American Idol most interesting thing
about this show is that it is apparently
still on the air I don't know if it's an
indication that I'm out of touch or that
American Idol is irrelevant but until
this moment I thought American Idol was
canceled years ago be that as it may um
it was back in the cultural conversation
ever so briefly this week but not for
anything related to music or singing
instead it was the story of one
contestant
and more specifically a judge's reaction
to that story
that had people talking watch in May
um a gunman walked into my school
I was in art room one
he shot up art room two
before he made his way to art room one
uh lost a lot of friends
eight students were killed uh two
teachers were killed and uh it's just
really been Negative Man Santa Fe had a
bad rap here since 2018.
what you doing Katie I
fax
this is not okay you should be singing
here because you love music it's true
because you don't have to go through
them
I agree you didn't have to lose eight
friends
I hope that you remind people that we
have to change because you know what I'm
they ask you how you are you just have
to say that you're that you're fine when
you're not really fine but you just
can't get into it because they would
never understand now before we deal with
the substance of Katy Perry's response
to the extent that it had any substance
we cannot ignore the incredible
narcissism on display here by her you
know what I'm scared too he is calmly
recounting his own horrific experience
and Perry used it as a platform to put
this they put on this over-the-top
emotional performance she even relates
it back to herself somehow as her fellow
judges comfort her they start patting
her on the back and comforting her while
the kid who was actually in the shooting
stands there and watches here's a hint
if someone is telling you about
something awful that happened to them
your response should not contain the
words I or me unless you're saying
something like I'm so sorry or I'm here
for you but if you're attempting to put
yourself at the center of this person's
suffering or deflect from it so the
focus is on you and your own emotions
then you are a classic narcissist and
maybe worst of all you're creating an
incredibly awkward situation for
everyone else who has to be in the room
with your lack of self-awareness I can
only imagine how comfortable it must
have been for that young man to be
standing there not sure what to say or
how to respond as Katy Perry launches
into her camera ready monologue like
she's auditioning for a soap opera
a monologue that was planned by the way
considering that the judges would have
known ahead of time that a contestant
was coming up who'd been in a mass
shooting I mean I understand that this
is a very cynical interpretation of
events
but I've been around long enough and
I've been in media long enough and I've
met enough of these sorts of people to
justify my cynicism but what about the
actual point she was making in her
scripted diatribe she says that the
country has failed the victims and
survivors of this school shooting and of
course she means specifically that it
failed by not passing enough gun control
laws to prevent the shooting from
happening never mind that the shooter
already broke a dozen different laws in
carrying out his crime it's unclear how
exactly it would have helped to add one
or two more laws onto the pile that the
killer was already determined to
disregard you can only make an act
illegal so many times before the laws
start to become redundant and therefore
useless
yeah this is what we so often do in our
culture when a bad thing happens we we
declare that the bad thing is the result
of some sort of failure it's always a
systemic failure failure of government
of policy people like Katy Perry take
solace in the idea that all tragedies
are policy failures because and really
all bad things you know they say poverty
is a policy failure too because for one
thing it gives them an excuse to push
their political agenda obviously but for
another it Comforts them to think that
the right policies if we could finally
land on them would banish all the bad
things from our midst when Perry says
that the country failed because there
was a school shooting what she means is
that we ought to have a country where
there are no shootings at all and she's
right in the sense that every mass
shooting and every bad thing shouldn't
happen that's why it's a very bad thing
if there's something that's evil like
any evil shouldn't happen but Perry like
any other leftist believes that a
country without any murder without any
bad people doing bad things is actually
practically achievable and that it can
be achieved through policy the irony of
course is that the utopianists who
imagined that a world of perfect peace
and Harmony can really be achieved 10
through their policies to create a world
that is ever farther away from peace and
Harmony world's like uh the world of
Chicago for example people with Katy
Perry's worldview
run most of our major American cities
and most of our major American cities
are violent crime and disease-ridden
Hell holes which actually isn't all that
ironic when you realize that effective
governance means understanding human
nature and understanding human nature
means acknowledging that bad people will
always exist and they will always do bad
things it's still true that a school
shooting represents a failure in fact
it's a whole series of failures
but they're mostly the kinds of failures
that Katy Perry and her ilk never want
to talk about and they're the kinds of
failures we skip over focusing instead
on debates over gun control
and that itself is also a failure
one which only ensures that this kind of
thing will keep happening with the same
or greater frequency
and that is why Katy Perry is today
finally cancer
[Music]